foreign
there are some simple steps you can take
to prepare your whanau and your home for
extreme weather as our climate changes
we expect to see average temperatures
increase
the warmer atmosphere will hold more
moisture so rainfall is predicted to
increase and we will see more frequent
heavy rainfall events
prepare before the rain sets in
make sure you clean out gutters or
debris trim your trees to make sure
they're not encroaching on your driveway
in case Emergency Services Vehicles need
to get through
if your property is prone to flooding
make sure you have sandbags ready or
alternatively stock up on some tub
pollens and some empty sacks that you
can fill
and if you need to store precious
materials out in your sheds or your
garages store them up high
for more detailed information and to put
together a plan for your whanau visit
getready.govt.nz
[Music]
thank you